hi i'm adam scott i'm ben stiller i'm
britt lauer hey i'm jen tulleck i'm
deichen lachman tramell thomann dan
erickson and we're here to answer your
burning questions for buzzfeed from
season one of severance
[Music]
getting to see trammell dance was really
fun
yeah
a chicken walked onto our set one day
and spent the afternoon hanging out in
the office
what it showed up near the garbage
dumpster
outside of the stage
in the bronx and it was like a lone
chicken the bronx chicken it was very
friendly it was like sitting on the
sound guy's shoulder yeah a set pet i
love filming the kind eye scene with
adam because it was the first time in
that season that i broke character
[Music]
i feel like that the easy choice is the
music dance experience because it was
just glorious in every single way but i
did also love jen reminded me earlier of
the non-dinner dinner which was just an
incredibly fun
night to like sit and watch these people
night and a half night and a half yeah
enact this ridiculous event and such an
incredible group of actors those people
they were rad one of the things that i
really valued being a part of this was
the fact that we were able to do what we
did in the midst of a pandemic
you know we had so many people that were
on board to help push this forward and
create some really beautiful art
[Music]
well we had it pretty well mapped out by
that point i don't know how much you
guys knew though i feel like it was sort
of case by case what you guys wanted to
know and yeah
my character is on the outside world the
entire time i thought i didn't need to
be privy to what was happening on the
inside if she wasn't and so i i kind of
intentionally kept myself away from some
of the buttons on some of the storylines
towards the end of the season so i
watched it with friends
um for the first time and there were a
couple of twists where i was like oh
because i didn't know and when you say
you watch it with friends do you mean
jennifer aniston courtney cox yeah david
was not there
but um matthew perry my friends are the
friends that's not a big deal that's
cool you know when we were making the
show nobody knew we were making the show
or really cared that we were making the
show because we were just making it in
our bubble and shooting the whole series
so it was kind of like they weren't like
big like this you know this the twists
and turns were like okay hopefully
people will think this is cool but it
nobody really you know the show didn't
really exist for anybody except for us
making it and we were doing it for about
a year and a half altogether so it was
uh after a while i was like i wonder if
anybody's even gonna
watch this i remember like a month and a
half after we started airing talking to
ben on the phone and we were just sort
of like
can you believe people care now about
these
these big things these big or just to
hear like like i was saying like any and
audi for like yeah yeah
nobody knew what i meant yeah and i was
like now the first time i heard somebody
say like his indians think they're
saying yeah
i sort of thought of it as the duality
of a single person so the ego versus the
id the ini is kind of this raw material
that is
hasn't been affected by years of
memories and the stories that we tell
ourselves and my audi is much more seen
in a presentational scenario so she's
much more aware that other people are
looking at her whereas uh any heli
doesn't really care what anyone thinks
so she's uh she's got that like teenage
angst so i sort of
tapped into
the rebellion of being a teenager
yeah we were
circling as we were leading up to
shooting the show like how to do it like
if you approach this like two like you
said like two different characters or
and i remember ben telling me a story
about visiting michael keaton on the set
of uh multiplicity i think and seeing
that he had like a char like a white
board or something with like charts
because he played like seven different
versions of the same character in that
movie so he had a chart with like a
diagram of where each version of the
character was at a different point in
the in the story that's the only time i
ever met michael keaton yeah
i do have a heli kind of graphic novel
that i i drew out pictures uh on my wall
so that i knew because we were shooting
kind of out of order yeah and i drew
little pictures of like helly's action
scene so i could go
oh i've smashed through a window here
and then
just publish that now
i saw that it's pretty cool i think
whatever level of difficulty you think
it might be for actors to do this it was
compounded by uh the fact that we were
shooting the episodes out of order too
and like a movie we weren't shooting
episode by episode but we shoot pieces
of episode across the nine or ten months
that we were shooting so they had to
sometimes on one day do parts of
episodes from you know like three or
four different episodes and have to be
jumping around and where they were and
any or audi so it was really really i
think very challenging for you guys
[Music]
i was very fortunate to be able to read
like all of the scripts at once and i
just couldn't put it down ben you told
me when we met on skype he was very
reluctant to tell me because when we met
i it was still up in the air whether i
was going to be able to do it or not and
it was such an extraordinary experience
to to work with him because like he's an
actor as well and so you know he takes
his time with you and wants to try so
many things and it just felt like
a different experience usually when you
work it's just like go go go and
obviously they had days like that but to
really have the liberty to take so much
time and and try so many things to get
miss casey just right was such a
blessing
[Music]
i can't quite describe what it's like to
walk into a room where there's like 54
images of you spinning on giant
cubes but i think i i actually felt a
bit nauseous when i walked into the room
that morning and we were joking that
it's either an actress like
greatest fantasy or their worst
nightmare
or both at the same time
so uh
yeah i was kind of using that shock that
literal shock of seeing myself so much
uh in the
that's what's happening with with heli
as well and
that's that whole scene was
choreographed so beautifully with the
camera movement and
just literally all the moving pieces of
um the set design he was stunning in
that dress oh that was beautiful
[Music]
it was amazing i think i was physically
trembling to the point where i was
trying to steady my own leg under the
table in the scene and i was like just
use it like don't be weird she's just
such a brilliant artist no two takes
felt the same she's incredibly generous
she's she listens and um she's also just
a badass gal so i really felt very lucky
that i got to
be in any scenes with her at all
it was a long process like we saw a lot
of people
it was something that you know each of
the characters
ben and i had already discussed a lot in
depth and and already had some very
specific ideas but also really wanted to
be surprised and wanted to sort of
discover
stuff that we didn't know about these
characters via the performer so it's
weird and vulnerable and beautiful to
have somebody who's lived in your head
for years it was years at that point
suddenly become real and become fleshed
out this
improved version of this character that
you've been thinking of it was pretty
surreal
i remember when we were shooting that
stuff because we were like in the middle
of the shoot uh like ben said we were
kind of shooting the whole season at
once in a way like a movie we were just
like okay
if this whole thing works like if if we
have them up to this point if the
audience is like in
these moments are going to be so much
fun and i think we did did that that run
and the screaming and stuff we did it
quite a bit uh and it was just a matter
of trying to like you know go for it and
turn it up to 11 every time
uh it was it was really fun
[Music]
my theory is that all the characters are
slowly turning into goats
and that then at the end of the series
they're all going to be sent back in
time so the goats that we're seeing in
season one are actually like future mark
and helly and everybody it's it's a
theory i don't know if it's true or not
thank you thank you thank you
thanks for having us and uh go check out
severance on apple tv plus
[Music]
you